yeah I suppose this may be the ultimate
question for almost any long-running
franchise preservation versus evolution
[Applause]
[Music]
so I'm gonna do that thing I do
sometimes which is where a comment will
happen often enough in a video that I'll
get sick of replying to it in in every
time it comes up and I'll just do a
video instead so this in some ways as a
follow-up to the video I did about Harry
Potter called Harry Potter and the
heteronormative standard where I talked
about the the under-representation of
LGBTQ people in the Harry Potter
universe given that the author has said
that LGBTQ people do exist in this world
if we take that as a given there's a
severe under-representation now there
was something that came up somewhat
continuously in the comments that was an
interesting point but also see I think
kind of missed one of the elements of
something about that I was going for so
I want to kind of clarify it here and
address that there were more than a few
people who pointed out basically the
timeline of the Harry Potter franchise
both real world timeline and fictional
timelines so the books the the first
book was published in 1997 official
story so far as best I could tell
JK Rowling started writing it in 1990
the last book came out in 2007 now
setting wise and when I say last book I
meant that you know the main Harry
Potter series the the seven core books
setting wise it starts I believe set
either in 90 or 91 and runs through 97
98
so basically
regardless of when any given entry in
the book was published
it is a 90s set story so the result of
that is more than a few people you know
took note of that both when it was
written and when it was set and said
well given the time frame is it
realistic for there to be noted
you know LGBTQ characters because it
would have been I don't want to say less
appropriate less common let's go with
that for anyone not identifying as
cisgender heterosexual to be out
especially in a high school environment
and there's a certain validity to that
so I I do want to acknowledge that
that's not an invalid argument or
question to ask but for me it doesn't
fix the main problems that I have
because for me that argument only works
if you strictly confine it to those
seven books and you know if D and by
grandfather clause I suppose the v8
films based off that if you can find it
to those because if we also contribute
in the fact which I've pointed out
myself before it is it is a third-person
restricted narrative perspective meaning
except for the prologue stuff at the
beginning of every book basically the
entire thing is from Harris point of
view it's not first-person narration but
he's the only one whose thoughts we are
privy to everything all the information
we get as a reader is filtered through
him so if he was never aware that his
classmates were LGBTQ there's no
omniscient narration to inform us of
that so I do feel that that is a valid
point if you restrict it to those seven
books the problem is the argument that I
was making about representation was
looking at the franchise as a whole and
not restricting it
you
to the seven books which is sort of
where I found frustration because I got
the point that people were making but
they were narrowing the view from what I
was talking about I was like I'm talking
about this and they kind of went well
look at this it's fine but I'm like well
yeah you cut off the segment's where it
all goes wrong so sure it looks fine now
and by that what I mean is and I didn't
go into as much detail about this as I
could have been maybe should have part
of my frustration with Harry Potter as a
franchise is that it has as it has gone
on
JK Rowling has had continual
opportunities to basically back up her
original conviction that's what about a
decade old now that gay people exist
here be but for her to continue to claim
that and yet not only in the books
proper but now in things set outside the
school with new characters perspectives
things like fantastic beasts and where
to find them and all of the
supplementary material meaning
Pottermore cursed child etc if there is
any relationship details it's always
heterosexual and there were people in
the comments who would go well look how
do you how do you know that you know
people didn't come out after high school
I'm like well strictly speaking we don't
not for every character we saw but every
single character who we know some degree
of information about them from post the
last book if it puts them in a
relationship at all it's always
heterosexual every single last one
they're either in a heterosexual or
they're not another relationship at all
or we just don't have the information so
that was where my frustration came in
because I didn't think that you could
defend it when you look at the grander
scope of the franchise which was what I
was looking at but the reason I didn't
take my hat off
and go through my whole LGBTQ phase I
actually want to expand this
conversation out further from that
initial starting point because it brings
up the question when we're dealing with
franchises that go on for decades how
much work should be put into preserving
the standards at the time it was started
or adjusting it for modern standards and
this is obviously something people get
very invested in especially when it
comes to things like representation
because you know it as I myself have
said when a franchise gets really really
big and it continues to exclude you know
a fundamental fact of who you are which
you know for a lot of LGBTQ fans of a
lot of things they find themselves
continue to be excluded even as more and
more and more more characters get added
and and part of the reason I'm bringing
this up is because some people made
reference in the comments not only to
Harry Potter but also brought up Star
Wars because I've mentioned that
franchises I remember one commenter
specifically was like well Star Wars was
started in the 70s they wouldn't have
had gay characters in the 70s and my
media thought was look I wasn't saying
they should have had gay characters in
the original Star Wars I'm saying the
franchise is still going on we're still
getting new entries are we supposed to
be walking off to a 1970s writing
standard and acting as if that's still
the time that we're existing in like and
I am asking that sincerely is that what
people think should happen and I guess
opposed to a certain extent I know that
some people do think that that should
happen because that's often part of the
argument against certain changes to a
franchise put it back to the way it was
and that's not an altogether not
understandable thing because sometimes
changes that get made go really badly
for any variety of reasons characters
and stories get taken in directions that
are just bad just bad ideas they they
ruin things but it's just weird for me
the idea that something that is trying
to continue to exist and I would think
trying to stay relevant in modern times
that there would be a defense for
continuing to act as if it's still in
the case of some of their Star Wars 1970
the case of somebody like Harry Potter
like is still 1997 if you want your
franchise to remain relevant I'd have to
change with the times
now that's and I'm sure some people will
misrepresent me on this one in the
comments as they did last time my little
trick to single out all the people who
left comments but without finishing the
video it worked pretty clearly I didn't
pointed them out in any replies but I
got to go scroll through and go you
didn't finish you didn't finish you
didn't finish it in finish that was nice
but so much like there I want to clarify
here that I am NOT saying that by
updating with the times that you know
that means a ton more diversity and a
ton of this and until that if it doesn't
fit so like trying to think of a good
example for a long-running franchise I
mean I really has I really hesitate to
praise Frank Miller because I kind of
find the man to be deeply unpleasant but
you know it's what's coming to my head
someone like Sin City what Sin City is
is intended as something very specific
and it's it's in a very specific vein
and genre and vibe and that vibe is men
damaged men and the women around them
sometimes but jherich men and other
things they do
in that sense it that's what it is and
to take something like that
and I think the comics are still running
well they were last I checked it's been
a while but those did run for quite a
while and if that started updating to
reflect you know a more diverse
perspective for the the characters who
are basically you know the the focal
points of the narrator's of the whole
thing that would be that would have been
a betrayal of what the thing was in the
first place but when you look at
something like Star Wars where what's
the core message rebels fight the Empire
way of the Jedi you know kind of chill
kind of Zen find your path that Star
Wars that knee aesthetic so something
like that it strikes me as odd that
people say oh you're rooting and again I
do understand that anything any new
addition of any kind can be handled
poorly not every new addition is a good
addition it will always come down to
execution no matter what it is whether
it's a good idea or a bad idea because
you can implement a good idea of poorly
just as well as you can just make a bad
idea worse so it will always be a matter
of execution but like to suggest that
the reason why it's okay that something
like Star Wars or Harry Potter doesn't
have LGBTQ characters is because when
the franchise started that sort of thing
wasn't normal that's a really weird
extrapolation to me and it's the sort of
thing like I never thought anyone would
have made that argument but it came up
continuously like enough that I'm making
this video because the like I said the
reason I do these sorts of I don't want
to say rebuttal but response to
recurrent comment videos is because it's
happening often enough that I get sick
of replying to the comments about it and
yeah I know I never want to call that
people would even be making that
argument but I don't know that sometimes
subtext is it's odd like I'll get calm
and saying boy I I never thought of it
that way and I find myself thinking
really I didn't think I had an unusual
perspective to that my brain might
frankly work in a vastly different way
than I think it does like in terms of
how typical my thought processes are I
don't know there's a little
philosophical divergence for you
but overall it's it's just odd to me to
make the argument that something should
never evolve because if all you want is
the same thing well you have the
original just re-watch it if it's going
to continue it should evolve in some way
shape or form otherwise what's the point
and sort of circle back Harry Potter and
get to the other side of that critique
where people who are saying but it's set
in the early 90s it's like well just
because something set in a time where
LGBTQ people maybe felt they couldn't be
out publicly that doesn't mean that you
can't have them there or that you can't
find some way to confirm to the audience
like you can confirm to the audience or
at least very firmly indicate that a
character is LGBTQ or Jewish or Muslim
or you know from a wealthy background
poor but you can indicate all sorts of
things without having a character
actually say it in a way that means that
information is out to all other
characters that are present so I don't
quite get I mean I get the argument that
for somebody like Harry Potter said in
the nineties that students probably
wouldn't be out but that doesn't mean
they don't exist again though
restricting you just to the books I I do
give it a semi pass on the basis of we
have Harry's restricted viewpoint but
you know I wasn't talking about Justice
Holmes just those books I was talking
about the whole franchise and the scope
of the whole franchise I go back to the
video go back to that one and and
yeah I stand by absolutely all of that
like some people flat out ask me does
that change your perspective well no the
fact that it was written at a certain
time and was set in a certain time
doesn't change my perspective because
it's still going on
we're still getting new entries and so
as we continue to get more information
that it continues to still be so rigidly
unincluded that doesn't change my
opinion of why I think that's kinda
crappy I think I would give a pass to
something that was set that was written
in an earlier time and is closed off
within that time I don't just mean the
narrative I mean the franchise so you
know one of my favorite book series
efforts to charters guides of galaxy not
very diverse
there was one female character of note
and she doesn't really become
interesting at all until the third book
and that's really kind of her only time
to shine she doesn't do a lot and that
you know from my perspective here I'm
like boy that's just that's kind of a
shame but I look at when it was written
in the fact that it was you know too
closed off thing I can go well would
have been nice if it had been more
diverse it's not and you know anyone who
wants to adopt it change it do
continuations of it which there have
been some you know if they want to
tinker with that fine but you know the
original work that that is what it is or
God try I don't know I'm trying to think
of the stuff that I read when I was
young that didn't become a continually
updated franchise you know things like
that things that that were done and
maybe they had a little series how to
run but then they finished they were
closed off and they exist strictly in
their moment in time when you have a
franchise that is continuing to get new
entries it no longer exists only in the
moment that it was created or the
timeframe in which it set it exists now
in the time we live now with the
standards and expectations we have now
so I would feel it kind of has to evolve
again the nature of that evolution has
got a completely vary from franchise to
franchise there's no you know anything
being again I'll go back to what I said
before I'm not saying that everything
being me now must have a minimum
diversity quota and this and that no but
things should change and evolve if
you're gonna continue to be putting it
out there cuz otherwise what are you
doing from a artistic standpoint I mean
from a business standpoint I know
exactly what you're doing you're buying
another yacht will end on that cynical
note so yeah just kind of wanted to
follow up on some things from that video
and talking general about the franchise
evolution as a general concept so
whatever your thoughts on what I've
talked about here drop something down
the comments let's talk about it there's
a whole bunch of stuff you can do
there's buttons and there's links check
them out if you feel like it there's a
patreon down there but remember folks
you're the council I just run the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]